this week on bryan ross investigates
after protests lawsuits and federal
investigations
into the nationwide epidemic of
prescription painkillers
the makers of oxycontin agreed to pay
eight billion
dollars and plead guilty to three felony
counts
but no criminal charges against any
executives or the family that owns the
company the sacklers
we're joined by the artist who led
protests against the museums
that took big money from the sack
workers nan golden
people wrote to congratulate me but this
isn't a win
it's a spin there's no justice in this
case
and the author of the groundbreaking
book painkiller
journalist barry meyer but no one's
being held accountable
for it no one is being
charged with encouraging doctors to
prescribe
oxycontin unnecessarily when it wasn't
medically
appropriate plus counting the vote in
the most consequential election of the
century
what could go wrong and what needs to be
done now to protect your vote
and your country we're joined by the
former white house cyber czar
richard clark and this week's winners
and losers in the media
see if you agree with the editors of
mediaite about who's on top
and who is not well we are making
efforts to contain it by running all
over the country not wearing a mask
that's what the vice president is doing
from the long crime trial network
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined this
evening as always by my colleague at law
and crime
rhonda schwartz and ronda we begin with
the question of whether the punishment
fits the crime
involving a department of justice action
against a man-made epidemic that would
grew out of greed
the addiction in this country that
caused so many deaths and suffering
of painkillers opioid painkillers the
department of justice
announced action against the company
that makes oxycontin purdue pharma
the company is owned privately by one
family the sackler family
best known for the millions of dollars
they've given to museums around the
world
but the question remains is the
punishment fitting the crime for what
happened
rhonda purdue pharma
pled guilty to three felony counts the
company that makes oxycontin
and they've agreed to pay an eight
billion dollar fine
but none of the sackler family or
members the executives who run the
company
are facing criminal charges
the justice department called the action
a major development but many were
skeptical
we're joined now by two people who were
instrumental in focusing public
attention on the opioid addiction
and the role of purdue pharma and the
sackler family nan golden the artist who
has helped lead
the group called pain prescription
addiction intervention now with her
protests against museums that had
sackler money
and barry meyer the former new york
times journalist pulitzer prize winner
who wrote painkiller and empire of
deceit thank you both for joining us nan
let me start with you
we were there with you night after night
when you went to the protest in museums
and tried to get the
scepter name and bring attention to
their role in all this
what's your reaction to this settlement
with the justice department
people wrote to congratulate me but this
isn't a win
it's a spin there's no justice in this
case
they're walking away with a tiny fine
much like in 2007
there's no documents being released
there's nobody standing trial
they haven't finished doing their
investigation
the sackler family is still being
disposed opposed
and they didn't wait for that it's
not a good settlement it's not a good
outcome
it's not justice for the families
barry meyer the settlement was for 8.3
billion dollars the company agreed to
plead guilty to three felony counts
what do you say about it well we've kind
of seen this play before brian
uh in 2007 the company
pled guilty to a felony count
uh now it's just acknowledged the fact
that it's a serial
offender uh picking up on what nan
just uh said um
these are like suddenly immaculate
crimes
you know purdue who became involved in
some sort of pump and dump scheme to get
doctors
to prescribe more oxycontin but no one's
being held accountable
for it no one is being
charged with encouraging doctors to
prescribe
oxycontin unnecessarily when it wasn't
medically
appropriate and for some reason
the justice department didn't feel
secure
in its case or wanted to rush it through
and it
agreed to a settlement where the sackler
family didn't even have to acknowledge
that it had done anything wrong so
the question is why
wasn't this case like the last case
pursued in court let the truth come out
there
let the government win let the sacklers
win
but really after 20 years it's time to
have this adjudicated
in a courtroom rather than in a back
room
nan golden the 8.3 billion dollars
according to the justice department will
provide what they call
extraordinary new resources to help
fight addiction
if approved by the court will redress
past wrongs and will also provide
extraordinary new resources for the
treatment
and care of those affected by opioids
addiction
what do you say about that
first of all they've politicized the
opioid crisis
which is just so cynical
they're trying to make it go away
they're trying to rush it to
and i have a big question what is the
difference between the sacklers and
purdue
it was their private company so i don't
see how this distinction is constantly
being made
i'd like to see them go to jail much of
this this eight billion dollars is a
fantasy figure
they're not going to collect most of it
because purdue is in bankruptcy
so why not just go to court
let the truth come out i would be the
first one to applaud purdue or the
sackler family
for going to court reclaiming their
reputation
what have you but you know we're
constantly we're trapped in this
world of legal cowardice where everyone
says well there's two we're settling in
the case not because we did something
wrong
but because of the costs or the
uncertainty of litigation
after 20 years let's have the truth
let's see how it plays and let's see
who's not guilty
nan in your protest that you led at the
various museums
around the united states and overseas
you were very effective in getting these
big institutions to
essentially stop taking sacrament to
take the names off
extensions and halls that they had
contributed to
are you going to continue that i'm sorry
brian
only the louvre has taken their name
down
and tufts university what we've been
effective at
is getting the museums and universities
to stop taking their funding
but we're not done now the one thing
that has been um
we've been successful and that we feel
some indication now after the case
is that nyu announced that they're
taking the sackler name
off of all the doc all everything having
to do with a medical school
so the students won't be graduating
with the name of malpractice on their
portfolios going forward and now
evidently dia has wiped their name off
their website and the met is considering
taking down their name and that was the
first place that we did a protest
so it's sort of the most important to us
and finally barry are the sacklers the
sackler family members who are involved
in the operations of purdue pharma are
they off the hook completely now
well it depends what happens in the
bankruptcy court case
uh that they're they could get uh live
liability protection against civil
lawsuits uh
you know the justice department in
making this or you know trumpeting this
announcement
on thursday you know was waving a stick
and saying you know our investigation is
continuing
people including the sackler family uh
could be charged in the future
my only you know my parting word would
be simply
don't hold your breath they've
you know the justice department has
displayed its cowardlessness
in the past it's how they roll
and it's how i can you know anticipate
things continuing
lan golden and barry meyer thank you
both for joining us this evening
very interesting to talk with you and
we'll stay on the story
thanks miranda please do brian thank you
in a statement the sackler families had
any criminality at the purdue pharma
company was the result of actions by
lower level
employees the family will pay some 225
million dollars in civil fines
coming up uncertainty and anxiety over
next week's election
what's going to happen will the votes be
counted we're joined by the former white
house cyber czar
richard clark when we return you're
watching brian ross
investigates
next what some are calling the most
consequential election in american
history
election day next week or more than 60
million people have already cast ballots
amid uncertainty and anxiety over
whether the ballots will be counted
whether others will meddle in the
election whether votes will be
suppressed
joining us to talk about that is the
former white house cyber czar richard
clark author of many books on the cyber
wars and the fifth domain
mr clark thank you so much for joining
us what are your great concerns and
fears about
what might happen next week well brian i
think our greatest fear
is that we don't know um we don't
believe that the russians will
do exactly the same thing that they did
uh four years ago
we know they're active the fbi has
publicly said that they're active
trying to interfere with the election we
don't know
all the techniques and tools that
they're using this time
and how they're different so we
we have over the course of the next six
days or so
the possibility that they will do
something that we haven't anticipated
but what we do know that they've done in
the past
uh is to misdirect people on social
media
uh they tell people that
voting has been extended so you don't
have to vote on tuesday
uh they tell people the wrong place to
vote
uh that sort of thing now they try to
get people to vote
for third-party candidates or not to
vote at all
so there's that working of the system
through social media
the other thing we know that they've
done in the past is get into voter
registration lists to hack into the
state government
uh election bureaus and to access the
voter registration lists
now one thing you could do with that is
you could
rewrite it so that when people who are
trying to vote in person
show up their name isn't on the list or
their name is on the list for a
different location
what that does is slows down the process
makes the lines longer and if you can
make the lines
long in particular precincts
of battleground states you might be able
to affect the outcome
mr craig we know the white house has not
taken a leadership role but our agencies
of the government working on this trying
to set up
defensive lines
but you're right in the normal
government in the past
uh there would have been a white house
coordination effort to achieve a whole
of government
effort here that's not happening
but despite the absence of the white
house at the table
the key agencies are active
they are coordinating together without a
leader
so cyber command and nsa
uh at fort meade in maryland uh the
department of homeland security
uh and the fbi have created something
called
the russia small group uh which is
coordinating
both offensive and defensive
uh activity uh we're led to believe that
cyber command
is doing things to disrupt efforts uh by
the russian intelligence agency
gru so they're doing offense uh but
they're also
doing defense uh attempting to detect
things
attempting to block things uh
they are very active and that's much
different
than four years ago
a question for you dick from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
in the last election the russians
planted all sorts of disinformation on
facebook
what is face to face book doing
differently in
this go around
well the russians are still planning
this information on facebook
but at least this time facebook is
looking for it and facebook and twitter
have both hired thousands of people
and they're also using artificial
intelligence
bots to look for disinformation
they're finding it they're blocking it
but the problem is the russians just
then pop up under another name
always pretending to be an american
sometimes pretending to be
african-americans sometimes pretending
to be
environmentalists in the united states
but they're they're constantly changing
their names and it's a
never-ending battle for social media to
find them
but i would say facebook and twitter and
reddit
uh are all trying uh which is not
something they tried
four years ago uh unfortunately
it doesn't seem to be that level of
interest over at google
uh and its youtube division which
doesn't seem to be doing much at all
dick last week the director of national
intelligence and the head of the fbi
pointed fingers at both russia and iran
what's the deal with iran
well brian when they did that that was
the most bizarre press conference i'd
seen in washington
in a long time and that's saying
something as you know
um the very political uh
director of national intelligence a
former republican congressman
with few qualifications and intelligence
uh he's been there for a few months the
director of national intelligence
radcliffe held a press conference at
night it was very hurried
there was not much lead announcement for
the press to get there
and he dragged along the fbi director
who frankly looked like he was reading a
hostage video
and the fbi director in that statement
that he read said nothing
but what radcliffe said was we know that
russia
is trying to interfere in the election
well of course we do
um but then he added and so is iran
uh and didn't quantify or
qualify uh their role
iran's doing very very little compared
to the russians
iran appears to have sent out some
direct emails to people
in florida but it doesn't seem to be
very well
written it doesn't seem to be very
effective i can
only imagine that the reason for that
press conference
uh is that the president has been
yelling at his various subordinates to
do something
uh and when he heard that iran was
doing anything he probably yelled at
radcliffe hold a press conference today
tonight and say it's not just russia
it's iran
all right richard clark thank you so
much for joining us we'll be watching
what happens next week and hope to talk
to you more about this
coming up this week's winners and losers
in the media as chosen by mediate
see if you agree with what they have to
say about the president's daughter
ivanka you're watching brian ross
investigate
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors at mediaite
and we're joined by the editor-in-chief
of mediaite aidan mclaughlin
meteorite which select law and crime
trial network is all part of the dan
abrams media empire
and aiden the first choice for the
winner this week jake tapper of cnn for
his interview with the white house chief
of staff mark meadows
here's a key clip from that interview
we're not going to control the pandemic
we are going to control the fact that we
get vaccines therapeutics and other
mitigations what are we going to get
because it is a contagious virus just
like the food but why not make
efforts to contain it well we are making
efforts to contain it by running all
over the country not wearing a mask
that's what the vice president is doing
and aiden that made headlines around the
world
yeah so it was a pretty stunning
omission from uh
mark meadows who is the donald trump's
chief of staff um
you have to remember the context of this
uh interview it comes on a weekend
when it was revealed that a number of
advisers to vice president
mike pence had tested positive for
coronavirus including mark short his own
chief of staff
so mark meadows goes on the sunday shows
to sort of
clean it up uh and put a you know rosy
face on what it looks like another
coronavirus outbreak at the white house
uh and tells
jake tapper this pretty stunning
admission that the white house doesn't
see
it as possible to get control of the
virus he said we're going to try and
control all these other variables
um the point he's making is obviously
that uh the virus is something that has
hit every country in the world
and that is is hard to you know
completely avoid um
or impossible to completely avoid but
it's still remarkable for an official to
basically shrug their shoulders and say
we're not going to get control of this
virus
the the best we can do is just try and
live with it um jake tapper
was able to get that quote out of mark
meadows in a
interview that was remarkable for other
reasons as well and that has pretty much
driven the news cycle this week
absolutely it appeared that the white
house was waving a white flag of
surrender to the virus
your loser this week also from the white
house the president's daughter
ivanka why was she considered a loser by
the editors of mediai
right so jared kushner and ivanka trump
actually
posted ivanka posted a tweet yesterday
in which she posed with her mail-in
ballot uh and you can see her there
alongside the president
now this might come as a shock if you
get your news from president donald
trump's twitter feed
the president has for months been
railing against mail in ballots
uh and has basically accused the
practice of leading to rampant fraud
so the fact that the president is
attacking mail and voting
uh which has been adopted by a lot of
states uh during the chronovirus
pandemic
and then you have ivanka trump and jared
kushner posing with mail in ballots it
certainly points out a hypocrisy of the
white house's position
the president hours after ivanka trump
posted that photo
uh was back to railing against mail in
voting uh and also said that uh it
shouldn't
that votes cast uh votes received after
election day should not be counted
um which is seen as sort of his
long-running attempt to delegitimize
votes countered after election day
which is something that is done in every
election in american history
we might have a longer process this year
just because of the pandemic
but his attacks on the electoral process
you combine that with
ivanka trump and jared kushner voting by
mail
it was it wasn't a great moment for the
white house
and we've just got 30 seconds but she
was supposed to be the secret weapon for
the president
that's right and i think she's been not
the best advisor
for the president here her tone is often
conflicts with the president whether
it's on the campaign trail she
promotes initiatives that the president
doesn't really seem to care about um
and uh and it's sort of i think probably
a relic from an administration that has
a little bit more of a normal tone
absolutely mclaughlin the
editor-in-chief of media thank you so
much for watching closely what happens
next week as the election takes place a
lot to talk about
media winners and losers so thanks again
and thanks to all of you for joining us
and thanks again to the great team at
the law and crime network
which successfully gets us on the air
and gets us off the air good night
[Music]
you